you are deliciously thought-provoking
and unsettling what what Drew to this
character it's quite a departure for you
I just wanted to be delicious stop
provoking and unsettling and uh I
thought this is a great opportunity
no I uh honestly I I work with BJ like
20 years ago I'm pumped and
he reached out about doing this and I I
thought like I read the screenplay and I
thought it was one of the best
screenplays I'd read in in a really long
time and and I was like Absolutely I'll
do it and the character was fun and it
was just
seemed interesting and worthwhile and
then it also I like the framing as the
countries becoming increasingly
fractured
idealistically
um it was it's just kind of like
beautiful moment where this
person takes the time to listen and
think and and I think the movie could be
the beginning of people thinking about
listening to the other side and what the
other side has to say and and I think
that's an awesome opportunity to heal
uh look we could use some Joy right now
as well and I think you're gonna give
that to us by returning with Kelso in
that 90s show what is it like for you
and Mila to be revisiting those
characters have you shot anything of it
yet
we shot it yeah it's funny and it's
weird and it's very it was very
um
yeah it was like super nostalgic and
really odd like going back into the
basement like checking like going just
going back into the set was like weird
and then being around everyone and like
but it was it's just bizarre what can
you tease about it for it I can't it's
just it's insane the fact that that
happened is insane you know everybody
loves to see you two together they love
that Cameo on the boys too imagine all
the people how did that come about
um
I it was coveted and Mila says hey
there's a thing we're gonna do and I was
like okay and she was like we're gonna
sing this song and I was like okay and
then we did it
whatever you said I'm just I'm four
episodes into the boys right now like
I'm just like I wear I was like why now
I have to watch it and then and then
because I hadn't seen it and so now
we're watching it and I'm like getting
all involved with these characters and
it's very fun
foreign